привет, Стив, это Стив Каплан, ты
знаешь, я всегда забываю сказать, если тебе нравятся
эти видео, подпишись, пожалуйста, я заметил, что
другие люди говорят, что сегодня я
хочу поговорить о своего рода освоении или
закреплении русской грамматики, и это
своего рода моя следующая задача.  только что
закончил свой 90-дневный челлендж по арабскому
и персидскому языкам, я выложил пару
видео моего уровня, который не очень хорош,
но это то, чего я смог
достичь, изучая два языка в течение этого
90-дневного периода, если я был  на
арабском до того, как большая часть моего персидского была в
течение того трехмесячного периода,
нет, в этом месяце, 2 мая, две недели,
я собираюсь быть в Украине,
поэтому я говорю, что это возможность
для меня поработать над этими двумя славянскими
языками.  Русский и украинский На русском,
конечно, говорит гораздо больше людей,
чем на украинском, но мне нравятся оба языка. Я
думаю, что они оба прекрасны.
Оба языка имеют за собой
интересную историю. Вы знаете много
людей, с которыми я хочу познакомиться.  оу,
но проблема в том, что у меня есть хорошее
понимание, и я бы слушал
аудиокниги, и и читал по истории
и литературе, и вы знаете текущие
события, когда я иду говорить, я всегда делаю
одни и те же ошибки, и причина
очень  просто, и это потому, что у нас есть
привычки, поэтому моя самая сильная языковая привычка -
английский, поэтому в английском языке, если вы говорите
существительное, книга, если вы от
книги к книге по книге,
вы знаете все, что происходит с
книгой, это все еще  книга, в
то время как на русском, украинском или других
славянских языках это может быть
связано с ние конничи и соевыми бобами, поэтому я
понимаю теорию, стоящую за этим, но
когда я говорю, мой естественный инстинкт состоит в том, чтобы
просто пойти
[ __ ] или книга, что это не изменится, так
что то же самое  верно и для некоторых
других аспектов славянских языков,
таких как глаголы движения, например,
аспект глаголов, которые опять же я не собираюсь вдаваться
в подробности этих вещей, но
это вещи, которые являются привычками, которые
носители славянского языка имеют  d, которого у меня, как у
носителя английского языка, нет, и как
мне потом развивать эти привычки, и я,
потому что я буду в Украине,
сначала говорю на востоке Украины и в Киеве,
где они в основном говорят по-русски, а затем
во Львове или они  говорить по-украински, что я
хочу сделать, так это приложить согласованные усилия, чтобы
улучшить не столько для расширения своего
словарного запаса, сколько для улучшения в гайках
и болтах, когда я впервые начал
читать об изучении языка. Кто-то
описал изучение языка как
состоящее из двух стратегий, одна из которых
своего рода изучение общей картины, а
другой - это гайки и болты, и поэтому общая
картина - это много слушать и читать
интересный контент, в конечном итоге
приобретая больше словарного запаса, знакомясь
с языком, но в какой-то момент вам также
нужно работать над гайками и болтами.
по опыту обнаружил, что чтение
таблиц склонения чтение объяснений на
самом деле мало что для меня делает, я не
очень много запоминаю, поэтому я все еще борюсь
с точностью, и поэтому моя стратегия
Теперь я использую наши мини-рассказы, и я
делаю это, потому что я добился больших
успехов в изучении греческого, персидского
и арабского языков, используя мини-рассказы.
Я чувствую, что это очень хороший способ
сосредоточиться на гайках и болтах.
потому что происходит то, что вы знаете
историю я знаю истории я сделал их
сейчас на трех четырех языках я знаю
истории я слушал много много
раз так что я могу лучше сосредоточиться
на гайках и болтах IV  Я знаю о
разных аспектах языка каждый
раз, когда слышу рассказ или слушаю или
читаю рассказ, плюс по ссылке я могу сохранять
фразы Я только для примера Я сейчас на
русском и украинском Я
сохраняю только фразы фразы которые  воплотить эти
аспекты языка, которые я
хочу улучшить, затем, когда я переворачиваю страницу в
своем уроке, я просматриваю эти структуры
и использую только обратную флэш-карту, поэтому я
вижу это на английском языке я должен сказать это на
русском или украинском тогда  когда я снова пойду
слушать историю, я лучше
осознаю эту структуру  Конечно, и, конечно же, в
мини-историях одна и та же структура повторяется
как минимум три, как минимум четыре раза, один и тот
же размах, да, по крайней мере, четыре раза
между разными точками зрения, а
затем вопросы, вы получите
одну и ту же структуру четыре раза, так что с этим
степень сосредоточенности на структуре, не
слишком беспокоясь о значении, которое
я знаю, я надеюсь, что это
поможет мне выработать новые привычки, и в
конце месяца из Львова я буду говорить
на украинском и русском языках, и вы можете
оцените, улучшился ли мой контроль над гайками и
болтами, теперь предложите яджа Чуи
Тоска, такие вы видите там против
покрытия кассет, газеты, пирошки,
крутите, теперь
му-ху, руины, сужается, camisa que le paru
ski, да, пани, да, моя, да, я, я Нага
Ямагути, устал Ямагути, она  Молодой
не йоки
Программа Раджу, да, животное, нет, ката, ценность Яги,
Ламия Отис, проблема покрытия потерь
в коротком вундеркинде, в коротком глюкозе,
Вирджиния, если вы попробуете, Падма, да, но
да, да, но что такое составной каждый
журавль, о, он первый, Лэйни Ванилли,
может, мое сообщение о сообщении, сэр
и Томми о Дюканнах, Набоков -
дворец, хранитель, Крински,
яджа, чтобы изучить Чили, Вирджиния, история,
мини-рассказы, Котори Уна, да мигать,
да, Кичул говорит, что прикосновение это какой-то
инструмент для раздевания, но Потамус буксирует  ракета да
да кстати эй ветер орган эй молоток
польски но в основном смотрю Yahoo Chu
Nagre Волшебник нах какая-то структура айка
в да ракета но в основном как ножи
мисс дама скудный ключ это Аппа цели
ключ арабский шкипер негодяи ключ электронные новости моя
едкость нарусе чайный гриб  Hojo's Casati
chris cuomo ha ha Deauville yong-ho
верьте за зерновые зерна к мобильным
счетам сказать да, я имею значение парижские эскимосы,
которые находятся в como no nami taco shop с
диаграммой фильм Петровна махото Зуккотти
учит Италию всему, что они говорят, нет,
начало  следующий в крючке Тревор
три о Прац авати структура
грамматическая а много на мерон на марина
это робот протиум - это колли
Абуду Ревати журавль начни меня очень дисней
атомарность для бюджета о дерьме извините
это vinet вы знаете больше ладно это ключ
ладно вот оно у вас есть и вот как
я плох сейчас и наступит конец
мая и я надеюсь стать намного лучше
спасибо что выслушали и помните что вы
должны  идите к общей картине, получите ее, вы
познакомитесь с языком, и вам также
придется в какой-то момент пройтись по гайкам и болтам,
и если вы попытаетесь сделать гайки и
болты заранее, прежде чем у вас будет общая картина,
это будет слишком сложно,
тогда как когда у вас есть  большая картина, на которой
вы можете сосредоточиться на гайках и болтах,
и я думаю, что мини-истории - отличный
способ сделать это, спасибо, что выслушали,
пока
вы